an attack or an accident the question
ever since a suspected russian-made
Missile hit a Polish Village killing two
a moment of peril where political
missteps could have prompted an
unimaginable escalation of violence
after calm consideration the Polish
president presented his initial findings
in all likelihood it was an S 300 rocket
manufactured in Russia in the 1970s so
the next question was who launched it
and so far we have no evidence that the
rocket might be launched by Russians in
all likelihood it was launched by the
Ukrainian air defense system to protect
the Ukrainian territory
pitted land marks the spot where the
weapon hit in Farmland near the
Ukrainian border it's the first time
since the war broke out that a missile
has struck Poland with fatal
consequences for two men
both of the families are going through
sadness and grief and pain because they
went to work and have not come back
we will see what comes next everyone has
fear for sure about what will happen
tonight or tomorrow
Poland is a NATO member which means a
deliberate attack here could have
triggered a United response a possible
wider War
some initially wondered if this was a
test by President Putin something Moscow
has been quick to deny
I'd like to invite you once again to pay
attention to a restrained reaction of
the United States which contrasted to an
absolutely hysterical reaction of the
Polish side and to a number of other
countries
but the suspicion is understandable
Russia was firing scores of missiles on
Tuesday a barrage raining down on
Ukrainian cities
Rockets Ukraine had to defend against as
the NATO Chief pointed out at a meeting
of the military Alliance
this is not Ukraine's fault
Russia Bears ultimate responsibility as
it continues its illegal war against
Ukraine
tonight Ukraine insists the missile
wasn't theirs as the investigation
continues the tension has eased a little
but this is a reminder of how volatile
this conflict is how easily it could
spill over
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Poland